- À des kilomètres des stades
et des visiteurs internationaux,
ils se réunissent pour vivre
leur Mondial, celui qu'ils
ont bâti.
Sourires et photos croquées
sur le vs s s s travailleurs
migrants qui profitent d'une
rare soirée de congé regardent
les parties gratuitement dans
un stade de cricket enntntntnt
d'y assister en personne.
Dans ce stade de 13 000 places,
on ne vend pas de bière à 20 $.
La nourrququququi est en vente
est népalaise, indienne,
pakistanaise. Et la Coupe du
monde qu'on suit plus que tout
est celle de cricket, pas celle
tbtbtbtball. Ici, c'est l'autre
visage de cette Coupe du monde,
l'autre visage de Doha.
La plupart de ces travailleurs
migrants vivent seuls à Doha.
Attirés au Qatar par
les promesses de travail
pour aider leur famille
dans leur pays d'origine.
De fausses asss,s,s,s, selon
ce Sénégalais. Il affirme
que plusieurs entreprises
ne l'ont jamais payé.
- On te asasasas bien,
on te paye pas bien.
Tu sais, tu travailles dur,
on te paye pas bien,
avec le "time" trop long...
Oui, c'est ça, c'est pas facile
du tout, vraiment, c'est pas
facile du tout en effet.
- Depuis l'an dernier, un
salaire minimum de l'équivalent
de 375 dollars canadiens
par mois a été instauré
au Qatar. Certains jugent
malgré tout les conditions
de travail décentes.
"Ceux qui souffrent sont ceux
qui ne font pas attention à leur
santé", affirme ce Népalais.
(cri d'exclamation)
Bon nombre de ces travailleurs
migrants ne sont au Qatar
que pour la Coupe du monde.
Ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils
feront ensuite.
"Si Dieu est bon, les occasions
de travail viendront."
La majorité encourage le Qatar,
ma s s s se régalent aussi
des buts de leurs adversaires.
(cris d'exclamation)
Le foot est une évasion
temporaire, le temps
d'une soirée.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Doha.